[Música]
soy mexicana nacida en texcoco estado de
méxico ya muy corta edad me acerqué al
mundo de la danza un mundo que no
conocía pero que sentía en mi corazón
sentí esa necesidad por el movimiento
mis padres vengo de una familia de bajos
recursos pero una familia muy
trabajadora que siempre han sido un gran
ejemplo para mí unos padres que siempre
han luchado por mejorar por ofrecernos
los mejores lo mejor para sus hijos
me ayudaron a hacer eso eso que tanto me
llamaba la atención me acerque al mundo
de la danza clásica y poco a poco me
enamoré de ese mundo fantástico y quise
tomar parte de esos maravillosos
escenarios que pude ver por primera vez
y me quedé otro país en el palacio de
bellas artes a los 8 años entró a la
escuela nacional de danza clásica ya
para volverme una bailarina profesional
para estudiar una carrera que dura 8
años y desde esa edad empecé a encontrar
una pasión muy grande por la danza
fueron años de mucho mucha disciplina de
mucho trabajo de muchos esfuerzos pero
también de muchísima alegría
después de estar pasando por etapas de
momentos en los cuales puede presentarme
en grandes escenarios del país y también
de poder conocer a muchas niñas que
soñaban con eso también tuve la
oportunidad de ganar un premio y con eso
irme bocado a inglaterra a londres a la
escuela del indicio national ballet
para mí fue un gran cambio en la vida ya
que era una niña que tenía mucho cariño
de sus padres mucho apoyo pero había
algo por dentro que decía que tenía que
irme lejos y tener que volar para lograr
ese sueño que creció con esos años de
estar en la escuela y que para mí era
pisar el escenario de una gran compañía
del extranjero
con muchos esfuerzos y con muchas ganas
me preparé y ahí fue un momento muy muy
difícil pero también muy importante en
mi vida fue el momento en que mis padres
me dejaron volar abrí las salas y no
tuve miedo de irme a otro lugar a otro
continente
aprendí otro idioma y me preparé para
irme
en ese momento no tenía miedo porque mi
sueño era lograr estar en un gran
escenario pero llegando a ese país
llegando inglaterra estando sola
volviendo a un independiente volviendo
en una niña que a tan corta edad tenía
que cuidar de todo de su dinero
organizarse ser disciplinada y asistir
día a día les cualidad lo mejor de mi en
ese momento me di cuenta de lo duro que
era estar sola fue un momento muchísima
de mucho dolor también un momento en el
cual me sentía feliz de poder estar
haciendo lo que tanto soñaba pero fue un
desprendimiento muy muy grande
y algo que si puedo decirles es que
mientras más lejos estoy de mi país lo
amo aún más valoro más todo lo que tengo
y todo lo que llevo en la sangre de
méxico estando en londres después desde
momentos también en los cuales yo llegué
a sentirme insegura por ser diferente
por tener otro físico ser diferente a
las niñas que yo veía que venían de
otras partes del mundo
con mucho esfuerzo también logré
conseguir un contrato cuando no termina
la escuela como bailarina empiezas a
buscar el contrato en alguna de las
grandes compañías del mundo
fue un momento en que yo me sentía ya
como de ella me sentía en un país donde
tenía mis amigos hablaba el idioma y de
repente
consigue un contrato en el ballet de
stuttgart en alemania una gran compañía
que para mí era maravillosa tener esa
oportunidad y decidió y me alemania
realmente me doy cuenta ahora que no lo
pensé mucho para mí fue muy claro que me
quería ir porque tenía esa pasión y ese
deseo de poder lograrlo y que además
después de haber pasado por etapas tan
difíciles sabía que yo había estado allá
para llegar a ese lugar
hubo algunos momentos de inseguridad en
los cuales pensé tal vez me puedo
regresar a mi país porque quiero estar
cerca de mis seres queridos porque es
difícil pero siempre hubo algo en mi
corazón que me detuve me dijo no tienes
que seguir aquí y me sacaba sacar una
fuerza se acaba algo tan maravilloso que
me empujaba a salir adelante
para mí fue como en la vida creo que
muchos momentos son los que uno tiene
que cambiar para poder ser mejor para
poder seguir subiendo y para poder
seguir alcanzando tus sueños el momento
que yo decido dejar londres y llegar a
alemania siento que fue un momento en el
que volví a nacer porque ahora ya no era
solo haber medido inglaterra y ser una
niña ahora ya tenía 18 años y era mayor
de edad y me viera trabajar por primera
vez una gran compañía llegue a un país
donde no entendía nada en los primeros
días fueron muy muy tristes
me sentía muy sola y lo único que me
ayudaba a tener más seguridad y poder
era saber que tenía mucho amor de mis
seres queridos mucho apoyo y que ellos
me iban a ayudar a lograr llegar a donde
yo quisiera era muy importante para mí
tener ese apoyo mental y ese es ese amor
tan fuerte y tan puro que venía de mi
familia cuando yo llegué stuttgart y
aprendió otro idioma y les puedo
comentar que cuando yo estaba en méxico
yo jamás quería aprender otro idioma
porque había una etapa donde ya estaba
muy pequeña y me acuerdo que algunas
niñas se reían de mí porque yo no
hablaba otro idioma porque yo no hablar
inglés no tuve la oportunidad de
aprenderlo antes entonces en ese momento
me di cuenta que liza de alguna manera
volvió a nacer y tuvo que aprender otro
idioma también para que para poder
moverme para poder disfrutar la vida
para entender esas tradiciones y de esa
manera yo misma sentirme motivada y
sentirme bien en el país en donde estaba
creo que algo muy importante en nuestra
vida es aprender adaptar
adaptarnos a las situaciones que estamos
viviendo y de esta manera ser más
fuertes y poder vencer todo y salir
adelante
llegando a estudiar comencé otra etapa
empecé a trabajar empecé a tratar de dar
lo mejor de mi día a día porque había
muchas jóvenes y muchos jóvenes que
venían de otras partes del mundo que
tenían también ese deseo igual que yo de
salir adelante
y fue también donde me di cuenta que ser
diferente fue algo que me ayudó
muchísimo eso que al principio a mí me
daba inseguridad en ese momento me ayudó
mucho para poder sobresalir y creo que
es muy importante no olvidar eso tus
raíces esa fuerza que llevas dentro eso
es lo que siempre te va a ayudar a
distinguir te y a sobresalir ante
cualquier situación
fui desde el cuerpo de baile hasta de mi
solista hasta solista en el stuttgart
ballet y fueron años muy bellos fue un
momento muy importante en mi vida
y justo cuando yo me sentía muy bien
cuando me sentía que finalmente estaba
en un lugar donde tenía la oportunidad
de llegar a lo más alto que era hacer
una primera bailarina llegó otra
oportunidad de venirme a alemania a
berlín perdón venir a berlín donde ahora
estoy
en ese momento les puedo decir qué
fue muy difícil ya que yo tenía la
oportunidad de subir a la última
categoría en este lugar llegaron a mi
sueño más grande que tenía pero por amor
por querer estar junto a la persona que
tanto amo decidí irme a berlín y creo
que ese momento es algo que para mí
siempre ha sido fundamental
la razón por la cual para mí también
vivimos para encontrar una persona quien
al mes para tener tu familia tus seres
queridos alrededor
y fue cuando me di cuenta que tal vez
iba a tener que retroceder que iba a
empezar de cero en un nuevo lugar donde
no me conocían donde tenía miedo donde
meten inseguridades pero después me di
cuenta que dar un paso hacia atrás me
ayudó a subir dos más y que todo ese
aprendizaje que tuve de llegar a un
lugar nuevo donde no te conocen donde la
gente digamos que cuando estás en un
lugar siempre te tienen guardado en un
cajón y piensas que eres así y solo
puedes hacer eso en la danza puede pasar
mucho eso ahora que yo me voy a berlín
sucede algo diferente
me dan nuevos roles me dan nuevas
variaciones nuevas cosas que interpretar
que a lo mejor en el otro lugar nunca me
hubieran dado y que yo misma en algún
momento pensé que no lo podía lograr
pero cuando tuve la oportunidad era
agarra la oportunidad o la dejo ir y no
voy a poder subir entonces con todo el
miedo y la inseguridad que tenía logré
empezar a motivarme porque claro que hay
momentos creo que para un bailarín es
algo muy difícil y muy fuerte es estar
en el escenario tienes que tener mucho
control de quién eres controlar tus
emociones ese momento estar en el
escenario y sentir la energía del
público es mágico pero también si no
tienes suficiente control mental puede
puede terminar contigo el estrés la
inseguridad de si algo va a salir mal
entonces para mí fue muy importante
y no darme por vencida saqué fuerzas de
lo más profundo donde yo pensaba por qué
estoy aquí porque llegué tan lejos
porque tuve que dejar en mi familia que
fue un gran dolor porque tuve porque
estoy aquí en lugar de estar en mi casa
con mis padres con mi familia en mi país
son todo mundo me entiende pero fue
cuando me puse a pensar es porque amo la
danza porque quiero lograr ese sueño y
es la única oportunidad es no darme por
vencido justamente ahorita cuando pienso
que ya no puedo más tengo que luchar
y gracias a que a que tuve ese ese deseo
y esa fuerza que tenía guardada en el
corazón y porque aparte dije soy
diferente y eso me tiene que ayudar a
sobresalir después de tres años de estar
en berlín
me volví primera bailarina llegué a ese
sueño
después de eso a veces la gente piensa
que llegas a la parte más alta y que
todo es perfecto y que nada te puede
fallar y que eres siempre feliz y si soy
muy feliz pero también hay días muy
tristes días donde creo que ya no puedo
pero siempre tengo que volver a mis
raíces de dónde vengo quién soy qué es
lo que quiero para mi la vida sin sueños
no tiene sentido creo que uno siempre
tiene que luchar por ser mejor por
tratar de transformarnos y por tratar de
de ser la más mejor versión de quién
somos de siempre mejorar porque
justamente los momentos más difíciles y
los momentos donde más atrapado
y con inseguridad te sientes son los
momentos que te hacen crecer más por lo
menos eso me ha pasado a mí creo que eso
nos puede pasar a todos
después de que me nombran primera
bailarina
y siento que yo como como elisa cambie
porque fue un gran reto y me di cuenta
que si estaba y era porque tenía las
capacidades y también todo lo que había
vivido toda esa experiencia que tuve en
estos años que habían pasado me
prepararon para llegar a ese lugar y así
día a día tuve que esforzarme porque en
el mundo en el que yo estoy en la danza
día a día tenemos que luchar con
nosotros mismos porque cada día hay
nuevas bailarinas nuevos todos los días
de mi vida tengo que estar luchando y
sobre todo también con convierte a ti
mismo yo siempre tengo un espejo delante
y ahí es donde te das cuenta quién eres
qué puedes lograr y dónde también de
momentos donde te ven si piensas que no
puedes más pero justamente ahí es donde
tienes que creer en ti y es lo único que
a mí me ha ayudado durante toda mi
carrera a tener los sueños y querer
llegar a ellos
después de que mejor primera bailarina
tenga la oportunidad de crear una
fundación en mexico de poder apoyar
niños de crear el festival danza plan
que ahora es la manera en que yo puedo
ofrecerle a las nuevas generaciones algo
de lo que ha aprendido
pero no hago otra manera de renacer para
mí que fue el día que me volví un mamá
haber tenido a mi hija es lo más bello
que me ha pasado en la vida es la luz
más grande que tengo y la motivación más
grande y me di cuenta que todo se repite
ese amor que yo tuve con mis padres es
el mismo que yo siento hace mi hija y
que ella me motiva día a día creo que
como seres humanos tenemos muchos
momentos en que volvemos a nacer en que
podemos mejorar en que podemos cambiar
en que podemos buscar nuestra mejor
versión
ahora con mi fundación creo que es muy
importante ofrecerle a las nuevas
generaciones lo que ha aprendido y es el
deseo que tengo poder dar algo no solo
haber recibido todas estas bellas
experiencias para poder dar porque de
esta manera creo que podemos ayudarnos
mutuamente a ser mejores y aprender y
justo en este momento tan difícil que
estamos viviendo creo que es un momento
ideal para transformarnos para no
olvidarnos que ser diferentes no
significa que esté mal algo simplemente
hay que aprender a adaptarnos hay que
buscarle algo positivo a cada situación
hay que reinventarnos y tratar día a día
a pesar de todas las situaciones
difíciles a pesar de la inseguridad del
miedo volver a nuestro corazón a esa
parte fuerte donde podemos aclarar
nuestros sueños y de esta manera ante
cualquier situación tener una sonrisa y
saber que todo está ahí y que
transformarlos
es algo muy bueno y es algo que nos
podría dar mucha felicidad es cuestión
de creer en nosotros y hacerlo
[Música]